la baignade y est interdite et pourtant
hier en fin d'après-midi un garçon de 5
ans s'est noyé ici dans le lac des
peupleraies situé entre la rivière du
cher et le stade de foot de tours
le lieu est fréquenté par des promeneurs
et par des familles qui viennent
profiter du cadre naturel
c'est pour cette raison que le petit de
5 ans sa soeur de 11 ans et son oncle de
13 ans sont venus ici dimanche
accompagnés de leur belle-mère en raison
de la chaleur ils ont bravé
l'interdiction de se baigner son bout et
ni brassard pour l'enfant de 5 ans c'est
alors qu'un chien promener par sa
maîtresse attire l'attention alors que
les plus grands joutes avec lui le petit
de 5 ans échappe à toute surveillance
il est 18h30 l'enfant cool la belle-mère
fait alors appel à la police
le petit sera retrouvé en arrêt
respiratoire
une enquête est ouverte pour déterminer
les circonstances du drame
fragile psychologiquement la belle-mère
a été mise en garde à vue dimanche soir
pour homicides involontaires
lors de son audition les enquêteurs
apprendront que le petit de 5 ans et sa
soeur se sont enfui du domicile de leur
mère a joué les tours en début d'après
midi la police qui lance également un
appel à témoins elle souhaite retrouver
la femme qui promenait son chien entre
18 heures et 18 heures 45 au lac des
peupleraies elle a été témoin des faits